hey guys what's up this is andrew with
trainsenses.com so the very first thing
i would like to say in this video
is that i heard you guys after my last
video
a lot of you were asking me to put back
the amc ng
recap in the free area of my discord
which i did
so today i would like to talk about
different stocks i would like to show
you
some stocks that actually uh some people
from a discord asked me to analyze
and that are looking very nice so today
i'm going to talk about
amg about mara and about tesla that is
sharing
a very nice price action development so
let's get into it
[Music]
alright let's start guys with tesla
alright so you already know this one
but i want to go through this again with
you
because uh when a stock is so basically
the three stocks i chose today
are the stocks that are for me showing
very nice
price action development and that
respecting the rules of
the elliot wave theory as well as the
fibonacci
extension and retracement percentage
which is suggesting that this tool
will also work well in the future
so here tesla i start to analyze the
move uh in july
so we have a one right in yellow a two a
three
fourth so i've been telling you guys
that tesla is looking very nice you know
already one or two months ago that
this area is a very nice area to buy
so you can go and check it out guys um
because
here we were having this correction so
here i was telling you careful guys it's
not the right time the correction would
last longer
and i was waiting for this breakout here
in a green which is for me to signal
that the force wave here
is complete all right and so we're doing
a fifth that is probably gonna go
to the uh one or two thousand area first
let me show you why
one or two thousand i just measure one
plus
three and i applied to the bottom of the
force all right
and this is giving me uh one thousand
four hundred one thousand nine hundred
all right so this is the area
where i see tesla going the worst case
scenario would be the uh
0.618 so 1 000 in one or two years
so this is a very nice target i really
believe in the stock i think it's going
to go higher
and here we have a nice entry level guys
so
let's zoom in a little bit and let's see
what is happening here on the shorter
term
so on the shorter term yes i was i'm
taking this breakout yes for like uh you
know a few months i'm talking about it
and here we finally have it so the
breakout occurred around the 608 level
it has not been retested yet so we
expect to re-test you know usually we
have a re-test
to know if the re-test is likely to
happen or not you can check
how long was the consolidation and you
can try to guess if the market has
a lot of explosivity a lot of energy and
here
this consideration lasts quite long yes
for like one or two months
so this could be explosive for now we
have a small pool back but it can go
higher right so i'm explaining very well
on my discord by the way i
put back the link of my discord but the
memberships are not open yet
uh just a quick heads up guys so you can
come to the free area where i share
some information with you so here i'm
giving you some
tips on how to enter this trade if you
want to get in
you know quickly what i would personally
do as we're gonna start to trade in
september we're gonna share the live
trades with you
in the discord as well uh i'm gonna wait
i think for the second wave pullback
which
should happen in september which is
perfect because
we're gonna be fully set up and ready to
train with my team
and here so i would try to get in and to
uh take this
third wave so this is a nice setup once
again uh the kind of tread you can do
guys is to use the moving averages all
right so on the forward time frame
you can for example use the 20 as a
buying uh signal
and as a entry level and the 50 as a
stop loss all right
this is the kind of trade that i would
do next one
very nice as well guys mara so i have
not heard about the stock
before uh one one or two weeks ago and i
have to say that it's looking very nice
all right so i'm gonna analyze the price
action starting in march
20 all right and same thing guys here
we do some eliot wave counting we have a
one one two three
four five all right i can you know break
down this one as well
if you want
okay and let me put it in yellow
all right so one two three four five abc
one two three four five
abc so it looks like we are about to do
another one two three four five
it looks like it now let's see if the
fib extension applied well to the stock
so to do that
so you can see that the idiotic counting
looks perfect guys all right that's why
i'm showing you the stock
but you measure from zero to three
and you apply to the bottom of the force
and look guys what we're having it goes
exactly the top of the fifth here goes
exactly to the 1.618
which is the classic you know price
action development once again i'm
showing you these guys
all the time but it's always good to see
multiple times this kind of good
information
here we go and you can see yes this is
what i'm using so
usually when the fifth is extended we
have this kind of relation so the fifth
wave
divided by 0.618 is equal to 0.382
of the oneplus 3 which means basically
the fixed wave equals 1.618
times one plus three and oh look
what we're having this is exactly what
we had here guys okay
let's check if it was working well here
i didn't check so
i here it's gonna be yeah here it is
very explosive all right
we go to the four times five extension
so
here not perfect but in the third wave
it worked very well
so we expect the same phenomenon to
happen here so for now we don't know
where is one plus three but what we know
guys is that one plus three is here
already
so either we go to the one to one
relation or two one
one point six one eight oh it can be
0.618 all right so it's giving me levels
between 50
52 but 52 is the is the all-time high so
i guess we're gonna go higher i mean you
know fixed wave must go higher than a
third wave so it's leaving us with 75 or
110 levels
all right guys you can see how high this
stuff can go
so let's say we only go to 75 it's still
150
i mean you know and you can enter this
trade uh with
like taking a very limited risk all
right this is what i'm gonna try to do
guys in september
uh when we're going to start live
trading i'm going to try to you know
diversify the risk and take a lot of
small trades like this
and here what i would do the breakout is
very nice guys all right so same
i would use the moving averages as entry
levels and stop losses
uh we had a strong a lot of
consolidation here so we might have a
pullback if we have a pullback that's
perfect if we don't
i would start already to you know buy
some shares even here
because it looks like we are in the
third of the third guys so you know that
this
can go very fast so let's see and uh
yeah so the stop-loss i would use it
i would go on the first time frame even
on the hourly timeframe
this looks nice okay i would use on the
hourly timeframe the 20
and 50. so i think that this is what i
shared with you guys as well on my
discord so this is the type of threads
that i would do
all right and next last one but not
least guys
uh amd same is the first time i'm
analyzing the stock with you
so i'm gonna start here in deck 18
guys bam and as usual guys i'm showing
you the stock because
delegate wave counting is very nice so
what do we have here
we have a one two three four
five okay the third wave is not perfect
i will think about it maybe the third
wave is not perfect because here
it's not easy to find five waves exactly
but whatever
it's not going to change much about what
is happening here guys all right this is
a force
this is a triangle all right triangle
very often
occur in force wave position so whenever
you see a triangle
don't mix triangles with wedges all
right i've said that many times but a
wedge is a pattern like this okay and
it's making higher highs
higher highs is not good we prefer to
see low highs which is corrective
which means there's going to be another
wave high highs means we're it's
probably the last wave okay
so here we have a nice triangle with one
two three
four reactions before breaking out
retesting it
perfectly guys almost perfectly and then
going
strongly higher all right so this is
what we like to see
uh this is a very nice price action
development and
same thing yes i would use the moving
averages to enter this trade
so here i would use the 20 and the 50.
you know it depends on what time horizon
you want to invest
in but basically on the daily on the 4
hours the 20 in the period and the 50
period moving averages are nice levels
to
do this kind of trades and here i expect
this price action to go higher
because we are in the third only in the
third wave of this fifth wave i think
so once again careful guys i always use
stop losses i know that
some of you don't like it which i
totally uh respect and understand
especially on amc this is not amc this
is another story
so careful guys again because we never
know what might happen
so i would use once again some training
stop losses with the moving averages
and here we have a target for the same
reason guys
okay so i do the same technique as i i
use what i found in the elliott wave
books that is sometimes working very
well
sometimes not so if it's not don't use
it check
in the past if it was working well if
yes then the likelihood that it's
working again
very well is higher so we don't want to
you know trade the bad stocks when we
want to trade the good stocks
here it's giving me a target from
between 150 to 200 guys
so once again very very nice upside a
lot of room on the upside
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video i will try to
talk more about other stocks because i
think that it's very interesting for you
to hear about it as well once again
thanks a lot to
everybody on my discord because you are
you know giving me so many stocks to
analyze
that i'm seeing a lot of nice
opportunities and i can
share it with everyone of course i'm
gonna keep the you know
updating you guys on my discord on a
daily basis i will not
have time to do the same on youtube but
i will do my best to
to give as much information as i can as
as much good content as i can
so that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys